This is a quick walkthrough to show you how to log in to Conor's Clinic.
First, we'll look at the member site.
So on Conor's Clinic.com at the top, you'll see members.
If you click on that, it'll bring you to members.conor's clinic.com.
So you can just type that in directly.
It'll bring you directly to the login page.
You're not going to use the traditional email and password for any of our logins.
If you scroll down, we're going to use the password list log in.
So what happens is you type in your email, check the box, click on email link.
It'll send you a link to your email.
So go to your inbox, check the email that we sent you, and there'll be a link.
You click on it, you'll bring your rate back to this member site, and you'll be logged in.
So we don't use email password, you just put in your email address, click the button,
go check your email, click the link, and it'll bring you back, and you'll be logged in.
For courses, you can just go directly to courses.conor's clinic.com,
or you can get there from the link on our website.
Same thing, click log in at the top here.
Same log in page, kind of same look, go down to the bottom, put your email address in,
click the link in your email, and it'll bring you back.
And you'll be on the courses page again, come down, you can click on access course,
and then you'll be able to scroll through all the modules.
Also, for our store, you can get there from this link, or you can go directly to shop.conorsclinic.com.
Up here, click on the icon, click log in, and this is a little different, similar concept.
So you're going to just, there's no password, you're going to type in your email address,
it continue, go to your email, and there'll be an email, instead of a link, there'll be a code.
Copy the code, come back here, and paste it in.
Or it'll, I think it might have a link also, but if you come back here, this will be a spot to
paste the code, and then hit enter, and that will log you into the store.
So with all of our sites, we upgraded to the newer, more secure, instead of using the email and
password, it's sending a link to your email to be able to get in.
So if you have any questions, obviously you can reach out to us.